a mysterious sex box a 150 year long
dream and so many time loops these
sci-fi movies still have audiences
scratching their heads
stanley kubrick's 2001 a space odyssey
is considered one of the great sci-fi
classics and one of the most revered
works in film history the 1968 picture
pushed the boundaries of special effects
lifted sci-fi from b-movie schlock to
serious art and made everyone afraid of
killer computers after escaping the
clutches of hal 9000 astronaut dave
bowman is sucked into a trippy tunnel
right outside jupiter he is assaulted
with all sorts of lights and crazy
colors before winding up in a cold
soulless hotel room in just a matter of
minutes bowman turns into an old man and
that's when a black monolith appears at
the foot of his bed these monoliths have
been turning up the entire movie
sparking new stages of evolution
whenever they appear when dave reaches
out to the big black obelisk he turns
into a glowing space fetus this magical
floating baby is known as the star child
and in the film's final sequence it
floats out into the galaxy looking down
at earth did dave literally transform
into an alien infant is the star child
symbolic of humanity's next stage in
evolution could it mean something else
altogether it doesn't seem like we'll
ever know for sure it's origin
and purpose
still a total mystery ai artificial
intelligence is a thoroughly depressing
affair after all this is the film where
haley joel osment breaks down crying
because his mom abandoned him in the
woods
granted osmond is playing a lifelike
android named david but still you can't
just toss a heartbroken mecca into the
wild after all the world is cruel to
little androids poor david is bullied by
human kids sees his fellow robots ripped
apart and eventually finds himself stuck
at the bottom of the ocean desperately
wishing he could become a real boy it's
a wish that will never come true and
then there's that ending
after 2 000 years of solitude david is
rescued by evolved ai the creatures take
pity on the little mecca and using
advanced tech they give david one last
day with his mother that's how the movie
ends with david cuddling his mom happy
at last
some casual viewers had no problem with
the ending but many sci-fi fans were
outraged at the shift in tone placing
the blame squarely on director steven
spielberg ai was originally a stanley
kubrick project so many assumed
spielberg screwed up kubrick's dark
project by tacking on the sappy finale
as spielberg eventually pointed out
however the whole david gets to spend
one last day with his mother thing was
actually kubrick's idea more importantly
it isn't a happy ending the evolved
mechas are granting david's wish because
they're about to shut him down forever
they're going to kill this little kid
and we're watching his final
hallucination before he's put down if
that's not a kubrick ending then we
don't know what is
richard kelly's cult classic donnie
darko hit theaters in 2001 but fans are
still trying to solve this incredibly
complex sci-fi flick to this day the
plot follows the titular donnie an
angsty highschooler who narrowly avoids
death by a falling jet engine thanks to
a six foot tall rabbit named frank if
that isn't crazy enough the film soon
introduces the concepts of time travel
and alternate dimensions turning a
coming of age tale into a cryptic head
scratcher you're weird
sorry
yeah that was a compliment
there's a lot of questions raised by
donnie darko that you probably won't see
the answers to on your first viewing we
know donnie has to stop an apocalypse
but what exactly does that have to do
with wormholes how do deceased
characters come back to life what's up
with that demonic bunny and why is donny
wearing that stupid human suit it's all
so complicated that kelly felt the need
to release a director's cut to help fans
put the pieces together donnie darko is
a movie that demands re-watch after
re-watch and while it's possible to gain
a decent understanding of the plot
there's no denying that it's a mad movie
before introducing the world to the
cheddar goblin in his 2018 film mandy
director panos cosmatos broke onto the
cinematic scene with beyond the black
rainbow this psychedelic nightmare of a
movie features a telekinetic girl and a
slasher scientist who find themselves in
a battle of life and death it's been
compared to films like el topo and
eraserhead and according to its creator
the film's screenplay is only 11 pages
long as you might expect this is a movie
that takes its sweet time drowning
audiences with surreal images and sounds
that make you wonder if you're watching
a film or going on an acid trip the
movie prompts so many questions what's
really happening at the arboria
institute what's up with that glowing
crystal and what exactly happens to the
villainous doctor nile after he goes
beyond the black rainbow by the time you
come down from this incredibly
disturbing trip you'll either
immediately want more or you'll have
completely lost your mind
ex-machina is a creepy film that
examines what might happen when humanity
finally creates artificial intelligence
and what might happen
nothing good that's a lesson that caleb
learns the hard way after he's invited
to participate in an advanced touring
test by billionaire tech genius nathan
the programming prodigy wants caleb to
see if his imprisoned android an ai
named ava is capable of independent
thought the only hitch is that ava looks
like alicia vikander and caleb starts to
fall for her
you're impressed
yes yes
although although
[Music]
there's a qualification to you being
impressed ava and caleb seem to grow
close and after realizing nathan is a
monster who's creating female androids
for his own sick gratification caleb
decides to break eva loose he hopes they
can run away together and ava seems
totally cool with caleb's plan but once
she's free she kills nathan and locks up
caleb leaving him to die as she sets out
into the real world her decision left a
lot of viewers baffled why kill such a
nice guy well caleb might not have been
as glaringly evil as nathan but he only
treats ava like a human once he starts
falling in love with her even though
he's more polite he still views ava like
an object in the same way that nathan
does he only decides to help her escape
after ava flirts with him and makes him
feel special meanwhile she's tired of
being a slave so it's time for her to
finally take control
directed by christopher nolan inception
is a bizarre blockbuster where cities
fold on top of themselves trains appear
out of nowhere and hotels spin around
like crashing cars in other words it's a
movie about the power of dreams
inception takes place in the
subconscious where rules can be bent and
mental barriers manipulated but for all
its incredible imagery the film sparked
so much conversation because of a simple
spinning top the plot of this sci-fi
epic follows a group of thieves led by
the enigmatic dominic cobb as they try
to implant an idea in the mind of a
young business heir if cobb can complete
the mission he'll have his murky past
erased and he'll finally get to return
to the us and see his kids again and
wouldn't you know it the mission is a
success and in the film's final moments
cobb is reunited with his children
maybe there's actually a good chance
that cobb might be asleep stuck in limbo
for the rest of his life everything
depends on that infamous top if cobb is
in the real world it will topple over
eventually but if he's still asleep it
will keep on spinning forever the movie
cuts right as the top starts to wobble
which resulted in endless debate about
cobb's fate according to christopher
nolan however it's not such a big deal
if the top falls over or not as the
director explained the important thing
for cobb is that he's back with his kids
whether this is reality or it's all in
his head the only thing that matters is
that it's real for him
finding love is hard enough but if
you've only got 45 days to find a mate
or be morphed into an animal that makes
things a lot more difficult
unfortunately for poor david if he
doesn't find a partner in a few weeks
he'll be tossed into a mysterious
machine and turned into a lobster
however things start looking up when he
meets the shortsighted woman in this
society partners have to share a
physical similarity and since they both
suffer from vision problems it seems
they're a match
until she is blinded this leaves the
lovers in a tricky situation if they
want to make this work david will have
to blind himself too
i'm going to deal with a knife
do you want me to come with you
i'd rather you didn't as the
short-sighted woman waits at a diner
booth david stands in front of a
bathroom mirror with a steak knife just
centimeters from his own eyeball before
we can see anything though the film cuts
to the short-sighted woman sitting at
her table she waits and waits for david
to return but the film goes black before
audiences can learn if david did the
bloody deed not even the cast and crew
of the lobster know the truth speaking
with entertainment weekly colin farrell
revealed that director yorgos lanthamos
and screenwriter ephemus filippo never
came up with an answer for the film's
ending as for himself farrell can see it
going either way he joked honest to god
part of me thinks he does it then part
of me thinks that when the camera cuts
back to rachel vice i'm already in a
uber heading down the road as fast as i
can the actor also raised the
possibility that david could have faked
blindness so he could be with his lover
while still maintaining his eyesight
whatever your interpretation might be it
probably says a lot about the way you
view romance written directed by and
starring justin benson and aaron
morehead 2017's the endless follows two
brothers who escaped a ufo cult when
they were younger but are lured back by
a strange videotape once they arrive
freaky things start happening and they
start to get the feeling that there's
something evil hiding in the darkness by
the time the credits roll the endless
has posed a lot of complicated questions
what's up with the entity and the time
loops what's with those freaky statues
and why is there a crossover with benson
and morehead's earlier movie resolution
well the invisible demon haunting our
heroes is a stand-in for horror movie
audiences who like their stories to have
dark endings and as it turns out the
creature drew the brothers back to the
cult in hopes of trapping them in a time
loop this particular desert is crowded
with different loops some which last
seconds and others which stretch on for
decades if you die in the loop or submit
yourself to the beast you'll be trapped
forever that's why the cult members look
so young they've been repeating the same
cycle every 10 years at the end of each
loop the entity tears them to shreds and
they start over again it's all part of
the creature's need for scary stories
with violent endings it turns out that
the guys from resolution are stuck in a
time loop of their own a revelation that
adds new depth to the 2012 film as for
those monuments they all represent the
evil entity they were constructed by the
victims stuck in the loops and they're
meant to express how these poor souls
viewed the demon judging by the apparent
age of some of these sculptures it seems
like this inter-dimensional creature has
been trapping people for a very long
time
christopher nolan's 2020 sci-fi flick
tenet just might be the filmmaker's most
confusing movie yet met with lukewarm
reception by critics tenet is a high
concept puzzle box that's more
interested in giving the viewer clues to
solve it rather than answers
hell happened here
it hasn't happened yet the protagonist
is a cia agent who finds a mysterious
artifact during a mission when the
artifact is stolen from him he's
recruited by a time traveling
organization called tenet to retrieve it
the protagonist and his handler neil
travel the globe to recover the artifact
but nothing and no one is as it seems
that sounds straightforward enough but
things are never so simple in a
christopher nolan movie and the ending
of tenet is one of his most confounding
the film's core narrative centers around
the concept of time inversion that means
the entropy of objects from the future
can move backwards so things from the
future can get brought into the past
those in the present move forward while
the future moves backward at least in
the present to achieve this effect of
two opposite movements at the same time
nolan shot the time inversion action
sequences twice one normally and the
other with the actors moving backwards
getting your head around the concept of
time inversion is the first key to
unlocking the rest of tenant most
viewers are bound to get lost their
first time around as the movie breaks
down linear time to render it a circle
that's why even the movie's biggest
defenders say it takes another trip
around to really get it to click
whether it's the sight of a skeletal
bear or a man turned into a fungus
annihilation is a movie that sticks in
your mind but even more compelling than
the gigantic shark gator is the film's
ambiguous ending after heading deep into
the shimmer an ever-growing
electromagnetic wave that mixes and
matches dna biology professor lena
encounters a metallic humanoid that
tries to copy her likeness using a
grenade lena kills the doppelganger and
burns down the shimmer but while she
saved the world that doesn't mean it's
smooth sailing for our hero lena's whole
reason for heading into the shimmer was
to discover what happened to her husband
kane he's a soldier who went mia after
heading into the world's freakiest light
show and then a year later he suddenly
appeared out of nowhere deathly ill
hoping to save his life and ease her
guilt lena accompanies four other women
into the shimmer to figure out exactly
what's going on what she learns is
haunting the cane back at the hospital
is almost certainly a doppelganger much
like the one that tried to take lena's
place however there's something odd
about the lena who finally escapes the
shimmer when she hugs her clone husband
we see the color in her eyes dance and
wave much like the lights in the shimmer
did the real lena make it back home or
was she replaced by the doppelganger
somewhere during their struggle or
perhaps the shimmer altered her dna and
turned her into something new whatever
happened lena is a new person forever
changed after literally confronting
herself
inspired by the french short film la
joute terry gilliam brings a fresh set
of eyes to an old-fashioned time travel
tale in 12 monkeys the killer cast and
gorgeous production design are enough to
get viewers to still return to this 1995
classic even if the ending is a bit
mind-boggling in a post-apocalyptic 2035
james cole is a prison inmate sent back
in time to stop the virus that destroyed
humanity he travels back to 1996 to
track down the source of the virus but
is continuously haunted by dreams of a
little boy seeing a man shot at an
airport in the end he finally catches up
with dr peters who's heading to an
airport to start the virus outbreak cole
tries to stop the doctor and instead is
shot by the police as it turns out his
dreams weren't dreams at all they were
memories of his younger self watching
his future self get killed the purpose
of cole's tragic life is just one of
many questions left at the end of 12
monkeys we never get to see if any of
cole's actions change the timeline but
it's heavily implied that his actions
were fruitless nothing will change the
past stays the same and the future is
unavoidable the whole affair is a bleak
take on time travel that appreciates
repeat viewings the movie never changes
every time you see it it seems different
because you are different stalker is a
classic but by today's standards it's
definitely a slow movie watching andre
tarkovsky's 1979 cerebral work of
post-apocalyptic sci-fi is a test of
patience but for those who have stuck
with it the reward has been great over
the years many people have watched this
movie and walked away with different
stabs at its meaning a deeply
interpretive film stalker is as
confounding as it is profound based on
arcadie and boris strogatzky's novella
roadside picnic three men the writer the
professor and the stalker go into the
radioactive zone which contains a
mythical wish granting room the trio
ventures through a dangerous land of
paranormal anomalies and unexplained
phenomena all while philosophically
sparring with each other and exploring
their motivations for the journey when
they finally reach the room however
there is an inexplicable anti-climax as
the three men sit in silence what
happens inside the room and the
significance of their journey is left
entirely ambiguous what exactly is the
zone and how has it changed the people
who dare enter it the final shots of the
movie show that the stalker's daughter
has now gained superhuman powers which
are implied to be a result of his
journey this question and others are
asked from the very beginning of stalker
and its lack of answers still sparks
vigorous discussion over 40 years later
if you're at all familiar with
pre-destination paradoxes you might have
some idea of where this ethan hawk
sci-fi thriller is headed
pre-destination is based off of robert a
heinlein's 1959 science fiction short
story all you zombies this 2014 sci-fi
puzzle stars hawk as agent doe a
disfigured time traveling agent who
moonlights as a barkeep after a failed
attempt to stop the bomber that wounded
him one day in 1970 agent doe meets a
man called john who reveals that he was
born an intersex female named jane and
had a child who was stolen by an unknown
man complications during birth led to
forced gender reassignment surgery so
jane began living as john agent doe
takes jon back in time to 1963 to get
revenge on the man who created this
situation only to realize that jon is
the person who got jane himself pregnant
so agent doe takes jane's baby further
back in time to 1945 and the child grows
up into jane this is the predestination
paradox and it only gets more
complicated as the movie continues by
the end it is revealed the movie is
about a single character the agent and
the bomber are also the same person as
jon jane and the baby and it's it's a
paradox right but it can't be
paradox after learning who he will
become the agent kills the bomber and
tries to close his own loop that's where
predestination ends leaving us to
imagine jon's endless nightmare and
wonder about the logic and existential
questions behind it all
robert pattinson fans might follow the
dreamy actor to the ends of the earth
but apparently not beyond our solar
system at least that's how the reaction
to 2018's high life would make it seem
while many critics found claire denise
erotic sci-fi drama mesmerizing and
thought-provoking a majority of the
audience seem to disagree this is likely
due to the slow pacing and cryptic
methods of storytelling that denis
utilizes monty is a criminal on death
row who's been placed on a ship full of
convicted killers heading towards a
black hole he and the others are subject
to experiments run by the mysterious dr
dibs who controls sexual activity on the
ship monty manages to father a child and
he works to keep himself and his baby
alive amidst the intense psychological
pressure of dr dibb's experiments high
life is focused on sex but many viewers
are still unsure about what exactly the
movie has to say about sexuality thanks
to its dreamlike quality its most
puzzling aspect is its representation of
the box a room that the prisoners use to
stimulate themselves denise described
herself as pro sex in an interview with
slate and clarified that she sees the
box as something positive however in an
interview with gq she also said that she
herself doesn't actually know what high
life is about saying i'm not interested
in understanding honestly it's not a
joke i don't need to understand i need
to feel good about something that's all
i need
although cameron crowe's 2001 sci-fi
adventure was a critical punchline in
its day vanilla sky has gone on to gain
a cult following this ambitious thriller
is an english language remake of
alejandro amenavars open your eyes a
trippy warning about the dangers of
technology and vanity narcissistic
playboy david ames is in a horrific car
accident after his jealous girlfriend
julie discovers his relationship with
another woman sophia after recovering
david rejoins society and starts dating
sophia again but his reality starts to
disintegrate in strange ways the ending
of vanilla sky reveals that the movie
has taken place inside david's lucid
dream that has been going on for 150
years after disfiguring his face and
losing sofia in reality david opted to
exist in a cryogenic hypersleep inside a
dream where he can live a fantasy life
until the technology needed to repair
his face is perfected his idealized
fantasy world gets ruined by a glitch in
the system so david is given the choice
to either stay in the dream or leap off
the roof to break the illusion and
return to reality
look at this
i'm frozen and you're dead
and i love you
what david ultimately chooses and what
it represents is unclear he decides to
jump and break free from his dream but
he doesn't know for certain if he will
wake up or what the world will even look
like now after so much time in the final
moments we hear a woman's voice called
to him but it's not clear whether he has
made it to reality or if he has finally
passed away
the bittersweet romantic drama eternal
sunshine of the spotless mind is a
collaboration between surrealism experts
charlie kaufman and michelle gondry when
joel and clementine break up they both
decide to undergo a procedure to have
their memories of each other erased the
majority of the film takes place in
joel's mind as he recalls his doomed
relationship with clementine as the
memories get deleted after going through
the procedure he retains one vague
recollection of clementine telling him
to meet her in montauk where they first
met despite the procedure's success both
lovers find each other again in montauk
and start again even after learning the
truth of their chaotic and painful
relationship this might seem to defeat
the point of the sci-fi elements or even
the story as a whole but it speaks to
the movie's central theme of love these
two have a special connection and
nothing can get in the way of that it's
a hopeful ending although seeing the way
clementine and joel's relationship plays
out makes one wonder if they're doomed
to repeat the same mistakes should these
two really be together or is the love
that was strong enough to bring them
back together also enough to break their
old dynamic according to vanity fair
kaufman originally conceived of a darker
ending in which joel walks away after
learning the truth knowing that gondry
and kaufman disagreed over whether joel
and clementine should end up together
further enhances the uncertainty of what
comes next for this eccentric couple
[Music]